Laurie Lachlan and her husband Massimo
become parents number 23 and 24 to cut a
deal in the College Admission scam our
nischelle Turner watch it all go down
live this morning with a quarantined
twist Laurie and husband Massimo are now
officially guilty for their role in the
college bribery scandal they made the
guilty pleas just before 12:30 p.m.
Eastern Time
there was no footage released of the
remote hearing that lasted around 40
minutes but I was able to watch and
listen as it happened in real-time
Laurie and Massimo did not interact with
each other they were both seated with
their lawyers and what could have been
separate rooms inside their home the
judge appeared via video conference from
Boston Laurie was dressed conservatively
she had on minimal makeup she appeared
focused and serious and at times upset
especially when the charges were being
read Massimo on the other hand was stoic
the entire time he looked somewhat aged
he had a full beard it was entirely gray
when the judge asked for their plea they
both answered with the same one word
guilty their sentencing has been set for
August 21st Laurie's recommended
sentence is two months in federal prison
and husband Massimo five months our
source says the guilty plea was never
part of Laurie's plan and quote she
truly believes she was looking out for
her children's best interest and giving
back to the school
[Music]